a lot of games take on space travel and
distant futures and all that kind of
stuff but none with the scope of
civilization beyond Earth building a new
life on a new world and now having to
contend with whole new environmental
factors in the first expansion will
Miller and David McDonough co-lead
designers you guys welcome to stage good
to see you again
Chris exciting to see you oh so fun to
talk to you guys about sieve because
you're like this dynamic duo they're
just like ideas like spring out of your
heads all the time and I think the first
expansion rising tide you guys are
really getting to harness some of the
more out there ideas and bring them into
practice I think one of the biggest
pieces of feedback we got from our fans
was that while beyond Earth was great it
didn't quite go far enough in terms of
pushing the sci-fi or these interesting
mechanics that we'd introduced to Civ
and it was a it was sort of permission
for us as designers to really open up to
throttle up on this idea of beyond Earth
it's a huge expansion there tons of new
features from the new diplomacy system
being able to land on water and colonize
the oceans of the planet hybrid
affinities for new factions to new
biomes it's its immense it's huge man
just gave us the rundown right there but
we got to start with water water has
always been you know strategically
important as kind of a a barrier a place
to traverse and in beyond Earth a trade
route right but being able to colonize
water to now claim territory there's a
lot of implications to being able to do
that oh it's huge I mean it's one of the
things that we're really excited about
in rising tide is that the stuff that
we're putting in isn't just like a mid
game or late game or early game
adjustment these things affect a whole
game from turn one to victory even if
you don't ever settle on the seat the
fact that it's there and then other
people can it changes everything so we
were really excited about how water
gameplay works how much of a huge game
changer it is like you could see here in
the in the demo the art team is on an
absolutely fabulous job bringing this
environment to life and it's been a lot
of fun for us as designers to really
think outside the box like you were
saying I think those more out there
ideas about what would it even mean if
we could build a city at sea a city
could float now the cities the the big
idea is that the cities move they travel
around the ocean
the planet they can like be part of a
navy and they can act as invaders there
are floating fortresses or the way that
they claim territory the the kind of
life the alien life that you find in the
sea and how different it is and the
stuff that's on land so everything is
different when the seas kind of open up
and there's no barrier to entry it's not
like hard to do from turn one you can
drive your colonists right off the
coastline start out at sea the in fact
of the four new factions that we're
we're adding to the game two of them
started see anyway the planetfall there
oh really so water is a huge deal it
changes it's small and large so much
about how the game plays it's just
honestly it's like like like it's
intimidating to think about how much
stuff you guys probably had to tackle in
terms of how this just read you know
recontextualize it's so much about about
expansion about settlement about the
tech web you know let's talk about
technology a little bit because you know
with the with the expansion and with the
all the new sort of stuff you can tackle
it's got to be some new tech on offer
right well we've we've gone back into
the tech web and really done some
fine-tuning there and if you'll recall
from the base game there's this concept
of affinity that the the way that your
civilization adapts to life on the new
world and there are three different
types of affinities that you can devote
yourselves to harmony purity and
supremacy and one of the features of the
expansion is the ability to multi class
borrowing some terminology from RPGs
here we want to be you want to be able
to hybridize your approach to that
problem so that comes along with a lot
of new units that you can unlock new
hybrid units and upgrades for your base
units as well so that's a huge new
addition to the tech tech tree and to
your your military as well just one
thing to clarify real quick because we
do see now a submersible cruising around
underneath yeah whatever unit that was
let's explore the Explorer yeah so that
Explorer was sending a unit down to to
do an excavation of some kind but yeah
there is no the water and like below
water it's all one layer so yeah it's
it's designed to be seamless with land
so just like land has got you know hills
and mountains yeah things are getting
your way and then make the terrain more
interesting water has levels of depths
and it's not it's not a separate layer
like the orbital air yeah this is
designed to be all part of a seamless
play surface there should be no
distinction no trouble in a
is playing hybrid back and forth across
land and sea any combination is equally
powerful you can you can win a game of
beyond Earth rising tide without ever
setting foot on land without on land
that's crazy I mean it would be hard
you probably say sure maybe a couple
times you ought to but you can do it
you could do it and but this is not to
say that the rules are the same so here
we're seeing one of the progress or the
speed bumps you're gonna run into in the
ocean this is the hydro coral these
giant alien things that you're gonna
have to contend with on the ocean so we
want to settle it rst looking but yeah
they're sort of like mountains they
won't hurt you if you don't try to fight
them but they will get in your way and
if you leave them alone they'll grow to
fill to fill a lot of space in the ocean
so you have to prune them you'll see
some of the new units we've added here
this is the submarine you can attack
from a distance so we can we can make
room
but there are a slew of new units new
resources the the resource distribution
is a lot different uh-huh and I think
everything is a lot faster on the on the
ocean so you're looking game territory
faster but you can also lose it just as
fast so it's a as David said seamless to
play from uh from land to water but it's
also much different the characterization
is much different I really I'm just
really enjoying the like barnacle II
tentacley look of these creatures but of
course one of the things I really liked
about beyond Earth was how alien life
sort of transformed the early game in a
way and made it you know they're not
barbarians they are much more
strategically complex they are a much
bigger part of your early to mid-game
strategy in terms of how you're gonna
deal with them how they're gonna impinge
on you and you guys are bringing a whole
new slew of water creatures sure yeah I
mean here you can see like there's a
couple of amphibious creatures as big
like crab looking things and a couple of
really fast kind of vicious little
aliens on the sea and then those big
Hydra coral there's alien nests at sea
they've got a whole ecosystem a whole AI
sort of set of how they live and move
and grow at sea so every bit is as
dynamic as they were on land and then of
course we're going back and mate the
land one's a bit better too like they've
got to be a parody yeah there's some new
biomes coming as well definitely uh but
I'd like to talk
here's a little bit in talk about
diplomacy because diplomacy always been
part of civilization but we when we've
talked about this expansion you guys
have sort of talked about basically
reimagining diplomacy entirely and
trying to make it try to make it more
dynamic yeah and I'd say we what we
wanted to do was make a game out of
diplomacy because it was it was very
lightweight in Civ 5 and I think it
worked in sin 5 because of the
historical personalities that were there
but in beyond Earth since our characters
are imagined it didn't really work it
fell flat so we took out the sim 5
diplomacy from beyond our base game and
we put in a brand new system and I think
there are three components to this that
are important the first is that we
wanted to make a progression out of the
personality of your character so you as
a player actually build your character's
personality from parts and the AIS are
doing this as well so you can see how
their personalities are evolving over
the course of the game the second thing
we wanted to do is model the
relationship that you have with AI sibs
and this is done with values of fear and
respect so it's sort of Machiavelli and
it's really interesting
and finally Nick won so we wanted to we
also wanted the players to be able to
vote sorry right if you if you fear me a
lot or if you respect me a lot either
way I get what I want okay and we also
wanted the players to be able to
exchange power in a way that they
haven't before the the personality
traits give you these really interesting
sort of game breaking rule changes to
your Civ and using a new currency called
diplomatic capital you can make
agreements with other sibs to harness
their power as well uh-huh so it's not
just trading resources and it's not just
declaring war peace anymore it's really
an involved and intricate so it's not
just the favor one one for one kind of
deal we sort of tipped our toe a little
bit with a favors idea like it was the
idea was what if we could put the tools
to manipulate the AI there in front of
you and favorites was just a touch of
that there was a lot more potential
there so from humble beginnings the new
diplomacy system was grown very
interesting and yeah just sort of
diplomacy is something that you know as
a suit player I like to dabble in every
I don't know dozen turns maybe I'll
check in with people maybe not even that
you guys dismiss making it more active
because those traits you were talking
about those are like concrete things
that you are seeing and clicking on it's
not
like I just I feel more aggressive so
I'm gonna build more military units it's
making this conscious choice right to
put that in there the composition of
your sieve is something you actively
participate in crafting and it also sort
of simplifies the things that the AI
cares about but also makes it care about
those things a lot more so you can
strategize around what the AI might do
so if you're if you're an AI player in
my game that likes trade a lot you have
a trait that says this I know that if I
make trade routes with you you're gonna
like me more your respect for me is
going to go up so it lets us its lets us
work around that problem of AI is doing
things that don't make sense it's like
you know I made this deal but he
rejected it why this is a problem that
goes back to say 5 - this would happen
all the time
sure but by making the rule set clearer
bringing out bringing it out in front of
the player we we get that transparency
and really make a game out of it CID
likes to say the computer should never
have more fun than the player so we've
taken a lot of those calculations and
put them up front that's Indian it's
interesting to sort of think about other
realms of Civ and you know a lot of the
resources and units there's a lot of
sort of tabulation and a lot of ways to
sort of balance the sheets and so now
that's coming to diplomacy very
intriguing you mentioned a little bit
earlier David but some new factions
coming into the play into play yeah
we've got four new factions in the game
so far we've announced one which is
called alpha law it's a Middle Eastern
theme faction and without going too much
into their backstory all of the new
factions are designed to be someone more
dangerous someone more radical uh-huh
and they're both in their origins and in
their play style so so we like it
because it's another interpretation of
the name of the game like these people
are they're gonna raise the stakes for
everybody like not just to play as but
to play against when they land on the
planet they come with some pretty wild
perspectives on what they're there to do
how they're gonna play and the powers
that we've endowed them with usually
like heavily embedded in the new
diplomacy system make them real game
changers like they can break up in some
of the rules that would have been
impossible before or before this
expansion so alpha law and their leader
are Xie Kish we're really excited about
to announce here or heretofore there'll
be three more coming up two of which I
can promise our aquatic themed so to
emphasize the aquatic gameplay they will
even
fall at sea and start there right on
water I like you told me this sort of
one of the things that sort of the back
stories you know crafting the stories
behind the tech and behind these
different factions is something you guys
sort of relished and drawing from
science fiction and all this stuff the
thing you told me was they didn't take a
cryogenic ship like they weren't frozen
through space it was a generation ship
so I just think they like it's really
fascinating the way you guys think of
that lower stuff as well and sort of
building out the whole civics perience
yeah that's like that kind of like
storytelling they're like getting the
player to think oh wow what would that
really be like we did that a lot kind of
implicitly and b/e but running time
hasn't got a lot more on the surface
like we really want the story to be a
big part of the game to tell the tale of
who these people are and make that an
emotional sticking point or four players
and speaking of storytelling one of the
ways that beyond Earth sort of
cultivated that is through the quest
system you know giving players these
decisions to make where there wasn't you
know the fate of the their world was not
hinging on it it was little bonuses here
or there but narrative Lee it allowed
them to sort of build a picture of what
kind of leader they were are you guys
doing some more stuff with the quest
system and rising tide absolutely the
quest system has been expanded the
catalog of quests you can get has been
expanded we've added more variations to
the quests that were in the base game as
well I think you're right it gives it
gives a sieve player this window into
what's going on in their civilization
and give some choices that they haven't
been able to have in a traditional Civ
experience before one of the other new
additions in the expansion is the
artifact system which we saw a little
bit of in the demo and this is a way for
us to reward players for doing quests or
for exploring the world by giving them
objects either objects from Old Earth or
objects they love objects collecting
things so you can get like a football or
a Stradivarius or something like that
from Old Earth yeah you know just some
something things of equal value right
you're right or you can you can find
strange alien things so learn a little
bit more about the biology of the planet
you can also find relics from the
mysterious progenitors this race of
intelligent beings that used to live on
the world but now I have left and this
is a great vehicle for us to tell more
of the story of beyond Earth and to make
a system out of it
so you can cache these artifacts in for
a quick gain or you can save them up
in two sets of three and cash them in
for things like wonders and buildings
that you couldn't have built otherwise
so it's a really simple system but it
lets us do a lot of storytelling and add
value at the same time we've talked a
lot about sort of the the marquee things
coming with rising tide right the new
stuff because that's the exciting stuff
but you guys have been added with beyond
Earth with patches and updates and
balanced stuff ever since release I you
know so for players who are thinking
like they sort of knew the lay of the
land with beyond Earth rising tide isn't
just changing you know it in big ways
like colonizing water etc but also the
game has evolved in a lot of small ways
as well yeah if you haven't really
checked in with beyond Earth since its
initial release it's already a lot
different like we were listening to fan
feedback right away and they had lots of
great ideas lots of great things to say
about what they liked what they wanted
more of what they thought could be done
better and we did it all and then and
then some
so rising tide represents a very big
step above what what base PE was and so
if you're just coming to the series for
the first time or if you've been playing
B E religiously since it came out when
you get this expansion everything old
will be new again like it's gonna be a
whole new world to play it and when's
that going down it's coming out this
fall on pc and mac and linux shortly to
follow fantastic will david thank you
guys so much for coming on it's always
talking the rising tide alright folks
getting out onto the water that is gonna
be really cool
I can't wait alright next we're gonna
take a look at Ghost Recon wildlands a
new game announced this week from
Ubisoft this look is brought to you by
our friends at MSI